all together
now
in the orioles hall of fame
jay
jay
i'd like to thank the oriole advocates
for considering me for this great honor
i can't tell you how much it means to me
to be a part of this fraternity
with such great people and great ball
players we congratulate our 2021
inductees to the orioles hall of fame
mo gabba
joe angel
mike devereaux and jj hardy
watkins coming off a loss
on the first day of august when he
pitched against the tigers in detroit
that's a high fly ball into left that's
got a chance out of here
home run
off the bat of yondi diaz on a 1-2 pitch
his eighth home run of the year and the
rays break out in front
well b.a as we have talked before
he picks his pitches and he's pulling a
lot of these home runs but not
completely forsaking his overall
approach
not at all and in this case right here
when you're ready for the fastball you
can react to the hanging breaking ball
and that's what that was a hanging
curveball that stayed up in the eyes and
you see yandy diaz very quickly with
very good pitch recognition and then
turns it loose
we don't often see him swing like that
and he gives the raise a one-nothing
lead here in the second got to make
contact right here it's kk 233 on the
air with a couple of homers
chopped to first they're going to
get caremeyer there was a look by
mancini at the plate
but wendell scores so and run batted in
for kier meyer that makes it two to
nothing he's out first base on assistant
you force trey mancini into a difficult
decision here because he's playing in
and he wants to go home
but
i think wisely decided just to tag here
meyer take the out
[Applause]
first pitch to jorge mateo he swings
drives out towards right field manuel
margot heads back and this one is fair
and ducks just into the corner mateo is
off to the races he looks up he'll
settle for a double as marco comes up
firing and jorge mateo gets a punch in
the chest from wander franco i think
these two are familiar with each other
and just how fast mateo can be it's a
one out double and mateo a nice little
three-game hit streak after he picked up
a triple last night
he's one of the three fastest men in the
major leagues
and when he hits a ball into the corner
in the gap it is just fun to watch him
go there goes mateo for third he is safe
he's gonna jog home
that is exceptional speed from jorge
matteo
who turns a single into a double
breaks for third and comes all the way
home for the first run wow this is what
speed does to you speed will speed up a
defense
and zadino knew he got
had to be really quick to try to get
that ball because mateo got a wonderful
jump from second base so right there
zeno forces him to make a bad throw so
speed and the orioles are on the
scoreboard and it flips back to the top
of the lineup here for the orioles with
cedric mullins
hold on a second here's a fly ball
cedric mullins deep right center and
gone and as the new hall of famer would
say
wave it
bye-bye
a 3-2 oriole lead number 19 for cedric
mullins
this is all you these all go to your
account jj sticking around
well cedric mullins just keeps on a hit
and extends his hitting streak now now
to 15 games a career high
belt's his 19th home run of the season
and his 39th rbi and yes he's doing it
off left-handers equally as well
fastball the outsider plate and cedric
bond just goes out and hooks it out to
right center field and all of a sudden
the orioles have a three to two lead
there's nelson cruz cruz is one for two
in the game today he is doubled and
struck out
this one is driven into deep center
turning around mullins he's going to
watch it go
out of here
home run for nelson cruz
on a 1-1 pitch cruz belts a two-run home
run
and the rays will grab the lead four to
three
well they did it last night he does it
again tonight
his 23rd home run of the year
and the rays are back on top
and last night dwayne it was the
three-run homer to tie the game the
two-run double for the go-ahead runs
batted in
and what would turn out to be a
game-winning rbi maybe this is the same
thing and i'm going to tell you we
talked about how hard he hits the ball
you see that swing there so smooth the
carry on that ball that cutter was
absolutely crushed
at second base for brett phillips
phillips shoots it fair up the right
side headed toward the corner wendell
scores easily
phillips
will wind up at second and the rays have
a two-run lead boy i'll be real
interested to see on this replay what
happened down there with mancini oh he
looked awkward as that ball got by him
curveball
middle in that allows phillips to be
able to turn on it hit it hard
and that's just a ground ball that that
just ate up to mancini i don't know if
it took a bad hop he's in position to
make the play that hits something and
right over that right shoulder and so
the rays now have a two run
well the raise in double figures in the
hit department with ten bases loaded for
brandon lau
lifts it the other way down the line
toward the corner and that ball is going
to be fair
and that's a grand slam
an opposite field slam right down the
line
and the raves get a quick four
home run number 24
on the year
for brandon lau
well you wondered a couple things about
that one
would it be fair
and would it be far enough and the
answer is
yes
to both
with barely in parentheses boy he gets
that ball right down the line as he
tries to find it
it's got just enough distance
right off the fair pole and valdez
cannot believe it so a quick four will
make it 9-3
and lau has
[Applause]
won and there's a shot off the bat of
franco
he hits one deep and gone
his fourth home run of the year and that
one from the left side
so franco gets into the act and hits one
out
[Applause]
tell you what
that left-handed swing of juan de franco
was really starting to come into shape
you know early on
all the damage all of the good swings
all of the hitting was done from the
right side and now we're seeing franco
swing the bat
from the left side
and he absolutely destroys that change
wendell third margaux at second phillips
at first
two outs and a full count here it is
and ball four
so that will force homer on as wendell
will come in and score and the rays lead
is now 11-3 so luplow digging on in rays
lead it 11-3
and the pitch is in the dart rolls by
the catcher wins and the rays will pick
up another run
so margot scores the second run of the
inning it's now a 12-3 ball game
with two on two out raise up
12-3 the 2-2 pitch to matteo again on
its way sliders swinging to miss strike
three
and that's your ball game
so colin mchugh comes on and finishes it
off
and the raise
for the tenth time this season have
beaten the bald memorials and this time
again
they beat him
rather big time